moi je suis transporté au gène
conscience professionnelle je rappelle
j'ai des salariés qui se sont mis en
droit de retrait le 14 décembre se doit
de retrait a été levée des inspecteurs
qui sont venus contrôler les véhicules
et qui n'ont pas trouvé de danger grave
et imminent le 15 décembre ces messieurs
n'ont pas rempli un travail et je
rappelle que le 2 janvier au matin de 6h
à 9h ils ont pu les véhicules sont
partis à 9 heures ils sont entrés et
depuis nous sommes debout comme je
rappelle je suis prêt à négocier avec
mon délégué syndical mon délégué du
personnel pas avec monsieur jean musy
pourquoi mais pourquoi je vais devoir
négocier avec mon budget monsieur vous
puissiez pas de contrat que monsieur
n'zi monsieur au musée n'est pas
l'employer le salarié de la sotra vole
monsieur un budget responsable syndical
cstm certes mais j'ai pas négocier avec
monsieur jean musy parce que le passé me
rappelle certaines choses où il est venu
ici au sein de mon bureau pour pouvoir
me menacer même le frapper je refuse de
négocier avec ce monsieur